russia
russia uh what about russia vodka
vodka vodka cool thank you very much for
really kind of you yes and did that one
you were like cool
that was a lady i'm not going to be like
nah [ __ ] that idea shut it down you
restated it and made it your own and i'm
going to give you a pay rise because of
it sorry
so russian vodka if we have a suggestion
from
over here what do you guys want to wrap
up
the mermaid who broke my heart thank you
so much
i feel like you've seen deep into my
soul though
russian vodka the mermaid who broke my
heart middle of the room what do you
want to write about
do that uh
the metropolitan museum of art yeah okay
cool i like it do you have a particular
favorite artwork then
okay you might need to tell me what the
artwork is
abstract expression is called franz
klein i wish i'd just been like
yeah i'll just talk about picasso or
something okay
fran's playing the abstract
expressionist at the museum of modern
art
russian vodka the moment you brought my
heart if you've got a suggestion you're
here we'll talk about
keep the handle going
say that again you just keep saying
hamburg
i've said that already though keep it
going
she actually is tripping yeah what just
rap about hamburg fine
okay have you been do you know anything
about hamburg
you live there okay cool cool we'll wrap
a hamburg um people over here
when trump had people pee on him the
trump p tapes good lovely stuff
i mean it's topical five years ago i
like it this thing lovely people
this is a freestyle rap as i said it's a
wrap made up on the spot based entirely
on suggestions not written
not prepared not rehearsed and the
suggestions are
russian vodka the mermaid who broke my
heart um
franz klein the abstract expressionist
at the museum of modern art
and uh when trump had people pee on him
and hamburgers don't worry
it won't be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly tough currently bad as
you're expecting a privately educated
middle-class white british boy to be
let's do this
kicking off the rap black we're turning
it up gonna purify it three times call
it smirnoff
even though the flavor's whack it can
easily be beat i prefer to get potato
screw with that wheat no i keep it in
the freezer serve it cold easier
if you wanna flavor it with cucumber
please sir tease my palate with the
vegetal hues
actually vodka easy thing to do and if
you mix a little bit of juniper in there
it turns right into chin people never
aware it's just a little bass spirit
like forty percent
technically eighty percent is continent
uses proof
not abv i discuss there they knock it
back seven times a week in russia
putin doing shooters in the kremlin
saying
oh yes you can bring all my friends in
so much vodka on offer for me
and bring it in drunk with the kgb and
then we go and torture navalny
the opposition leader recently went on a
hunger strike
he was there in prison if you thought
he'd ring vodka you'll be forgiven for
thinking that he might it's the national
grief but sadly he's like no
i'm in the clinch i will never eat so i
never need to piss let me move on
talk about the abstract impressionist i
believe a lot of them were based in
russia but in new york as well
and i really discover in the 1950s time
ago
is he even related to like mark rothko
another thing
oh cheering on the time but wanna talk
about the guy
franz klein hello my name is german you
have seen
all of my work in the great museum it's
really good it's closed now so you can't
go there but check out all the art that
i did it's in moma
[Music]
visiting hamburg not recently i was
there it's amazing so many of my people
did you know in the 1960s the beatles
they got really good they were playing
on the stage for april bond that's a
little street where you'd rage
that lady not so she knows it's true how
many people here to beat a hamburg just
to
a bus it was fun i loved it i can see
them they've actually got a blind museum
they blindfold you up and put you there
in the dark you can walk around with
white sticks
are such a lark but i'm not laughing at
any of that i'm displayed with my fins
played yes i'm a mermaid on a tiny
little rock maybe knock it out the park
hands princeton anderson
they're in denmark in the harbour in
copenhagen i'm aware
all kind of different to disney's one
caller ariel with sebastian
the tiny little crab i used to have a
number she drove me mad
with desire always wanted to be beside
her we had to do tea jobs because she
had no vagina
still it was great it made my dick swell
i love to rub my shaft right between the
two
shells and sadly she went away off the
coast sea
sadly she broke my heart and then she
ghosts me going back there
ah beside myself she's there with
poseidon and i wish you good health now
the lasting
i'd be doing back over to russia
producing the urine
and trump's there lying on the bed
saying this goes well i'm here in a
hotel i can't do his voice i can just do
the shapes of his lips
he gets a little glass he gives it a sip
he's like sup vlad
thanks for giving this to me a little
glass of vodka psych
it's pee he knocks it right back
consuming the urine
if he's here right now everybody's
booing i really hope we see the tapes
one day
but sadly you know if he has his way
yeah
[Applause]
thank you very much